vous pensez qu'il faut plus invité sur
les plateaux avec des mots jamais il
doit être bannie année mais n'attend
vraiment j'en ai rêvé qu'une fête comme
dans une dictature mais là on a perdu
des gens et cela finira avec eux j'aime
beaucoup andré bercoff mais vous délirez
avec tous ces gens là andré le voulez
bien sûr qu'il faut l'interdire
il professe la haine je dirais pas qu'il
est raciste parce que ils pourraient
nous attaquer mais il a des propos qui
le sont vous savez ce qu'il a dit dans
la séquence censuré vous n'êtes pas un
enfant de la république votre prénom est
une insulte à la loi alors ses sacs à
l'entrée du spectateur on dit la phrase
qui vous plairont dit la phrase vous
n'êtes pas un enfant de la république
votre prénom est une insulte à la france
ça peut d'ailleurs être attaquée parce
que c'est un terme de mépriser base et
partiale et quand on dit ça soit on doit
être interdit jamais ça tout s'est
arrangé elle a dit je vous informe
réfléchir a déposé plainte contre
monsieur zemmour sur le plateau j'ai
subi des insultes graves ainsi que mes
parents très affectée par la violence de
la scène que j'ai eu à vivre et que vous
n'avez pas vu ce soir je réfléchis à
quitter limite l aquitaine alors
l'attention alors oui c'est n'importe
quoi
alors qu'andré dire qu'il serait quand
même alors je vais vous dire ce qui est
n'importe quoi d'abord je trouve que
quelqu'un comme gilles verdez wiki eux
qui n'est pas il n'ya pas le les
neurones d'un enfant de deux ans et demi
dire que quelqu'un il faut l'interdire
complètement je vous dis la georgie bien
un jour vous dire des conneries on vous
interdire à casser de l'afrique et je
vais vous dire et vous serez très très
marie la liberté d'expression monsieur
verdez elle ne se délient salle à assas
que quand on commence et au long du type
est bien enlever la liberté expression
qu'on ne mange jamais qu'on a fait j'ai
arrêté quand on a su que je serais prêt
j'étais assis à la table rien dire dit
moins de 6 et les gens qui se font
massacrer un peu partout vous croyez est
ce que est ce que ces gens là quel
rapport y a une gueule rapport
aujourd'hui c'est uniao da ilha
difficiles sont ceux des noirs
l'esclavagé à la mairie à la nonagénaire
dès que j'ai su me andré bercoff
françoise nyssen willis ligne de la
culture mais si moi ce que tu es avec
mépris total les mâles blancs on à la
marre de voir les mâles blancs de plus
de 50 ans hétérosexuels ont attiré du
match très dur
violacée la justice et deux sont des
chômeurs est le racisme anti blanc n'ont
pas l'occurrence il n'a pas été puni
alors si en plus on regarde les
victimiser les chefs est ce que si je
vous dis la veille est ce que si cette
séquence alors vous dis non avait été
dans notre émission s quand on sait que
s'arrêter s'arrêter je crois sans toi
pire baïdu c'est du direct
c'est nous c'est du direct on est mené
sera pas été coupé racé comme je n'avais
pas scéniques abandon serait déjà plus
là mais c'est 10 à 6,10 à sur le plateau
moi je le gifle ça c'est n'importe quoi
il s'agit vous pouvez pas dire ça parce
que je fais pareil qu'en mai gilles côté
profs du journaliste qui le rendent
comme la liberté de la presse liberté la
parole ont cru en toi bien si je sais
que tu as bien les bosses mais d'après
la liberté de la presse en france
francois le prêt elle est très précise
elle est définie par la loi de 1881 à
fait a dit la liberté de la presse
s'arrête au racisme à l'incitation à la
haine
alors on se calme et on entre un père
bernard montiel
[Rires]
moi
selon toi mais je les ai vues elles et
en science du jeu les vues je les aimais
sa soirée alors vous savez quoi
alors j'imagine et allemand vous savez
quoi ça cause des grammy amis je pense à
tous qui a beaucoup souffert d'abord
depuis longtemps du racisme il ya une
séquence aussi dans l'émission où on
voit vincent qui discute avec elle qui
est en train de lire un message passe en
syrie afin d'élire tous les messages de
haine qu'elle reçoit tous les jours
voilà c'est ignoble dit de mal à venir
j'avais un dess alors il faudrait vous
gifle et coluche mais quand coluche
disait bien que lui disais on n'a pas le
droit de dire la france aux français
c'est triste ou la mère est rentrée aux
délires des projets d'humoristes toi
combien vous délirez la même temps les
chéris la liberté d'expression ne
s'arrête pas à vos caprices la liberté
d'expression et anti crise conneries on
est très contents d'entendre vos
conneries quelquefois je pourrais dire
le tribunal de l'intelligence pourrait
condamner de leurs mots pour son dernier
en europe juste chez d'oxygène pour
henry
la logar c'est la maison qui fait un
débat mais sous la boue tonnes d'oxygène
un délire ah bah ouais enfin j'aimerais
avoir
j'aimerais avoir l'avis des
téléspectateurs qui nous plaît et
jardinent mallié d'abord alors oui
doit-on et non non et encore a dit eric
zemmour sera pas tout et les non tu
faisais écoute moi bien
[Applaudissements]
22h02 qu'on y avait les pétales vous et
en 44 84
[Rires]
professeur de journalisme sont cons
[Applaudissements]
dans nos manières